today's the day that I've been looking
forward to but also sort of dreading
because it's gonna be the first time
that I'm picking Maddie to a set have a
photo shoot for darling magazine today
and Maddie is going to he's gonna come
with are you excited for this are you
excited about your first shoot what
about your bag I think he's gonna be
real into it such a good point is little
baggie
oh my little prince a lot of you guys
well actually I got a bunch of tweets
when I first posted that I was putting
Maddie in a backpack it is a dog safe
backpack it has ventilation so do not
put your dog inside of a random backpack
and leave him there because that is not
safe has got himself his special little
bag and he is ready to roll so let's
head to this shoe of it and see what
happens good thing Francesca will be
there and Betar so if Maddie needs some
company and some friends you will have
them
today is DJ mini Matt's first UTP setup
it's really working really hard today
to use it the new today we did piggy
sleeping we're about to pack up and go
home
he did a really good job over there
they're so precious
hey everyone today is a very fun even a
sad day because I'm taking that each of
the vet it's his second vet trip he's
already had some of his shots but we
don't get his shots at this set yeah I
could do I mean they charge you well
that's true believe the little trim on
his little Tootsie's we had a wild day
today I went to London scratcher why I
got six inches called a player Jenna got
six inches cut off her hair and left
onto Broadway but what I do want to show
you its own tree my glasses and this is
yours
which ones you like more the tube
totally very different styles but I
loved ones 1000 feet turn right onto
14th Street you're so weird not
sponsored I'm not sure why I'm so
obsessed with them I don't know they
follow you on twitter maybe they know
buddy obsession I think they do probably
cuz we were talking about it one of your
videos before I know here's the first
there Jenna thought I looking with
studious and here's pair number two what
do we think
did you like which one do you like
better - Lou - Lou Lou all right we're
snoozer loser loser loser snoozin loser
Kate the time is now he's gotta get
ready because we're traveling in a week
in one week Mr Man will be traveling
Maddie you want some water look he just
drank no you might want some more please
don't bite my nice person please don't
bite my nice finger out so Rochon uh
whoa whoa whoa did that hurt I just
tripped and and sub my toe off of the
couch anywhere my shoot state was really
fun Maddie was such a good boy Maddie
was such a good boy
oh thank you your face was he is that a
Lego it was it his hair oh my god that
actually looks like a like a Segway
picture dude it's like I'm all I'm like
it's like talk about its real quick
what's killing me and make it job I got
to turn it off with the fact slow bug I
don't know
I'm waiting my turn it looks the same on
camera this is like I pulled up to the
scene okay let's do a turn which way
back up these wheels these are big these
wheels are big crap I'm like fine off of
the scene such a difference sister
change from the pink one I feel like up
where they walk he pooped the math oh oh
man Bad Bad